[Musique]
e
un jour un jeune étudiant voyage en auto
stop
la personne qui s'est arrêté pour me
prendre en charge est avéré être un
apiculteur
non seulement il m'a conduit plus loin à
destination mais il m'a donné l'occasion
de visiter avec lui quelques-unes de ses
ruches fait émerveillé
j'ai découvert le monde grouillant des
abeilles odeur de miel de saisir la
beauté des couleurs les structures
parfaite verrions et puis aussi le buzz
incroyable de la ruche
j'étais complètement fascinée par
l'organisation de ce petit peuple
grouillant d'insectes j'étais stupéfait
à un tel point que je me suis un jour
j'aurai des ruches
je serai apiculteurs bien sûr depuis que
je suis apiculteurs j'élève des abeilles
mais en fait je me suis aperçu d'une
chose essentielle
ce sont aussi les abeilles kim élèves
finalement je suis un école d appel
alors voilà allons ensemble à l'école
des abeilles
le soir même de cette rencontre je me
suis fait une promesse à moi même je me
suis dit finalement je ne peux pas en
rester là
la vie m'a fait un cadeau celui de
rencontrer le monde des abeilles
grâce à une personne passionnante et
passionnée et donc cette promesse je
détenus je me suis inscrit pour passer
une formation d'apiculteurs dans un c ap
et l'année suivante
au printemps j'ai commencé avec deux
ruches et là je suis vite aperçu que la
théorie ne suffit pas quand vous êtes
face à 60 mille abeilles dans une ruche
vous n'avez pas le temps d'aller
regarder dans le bouquin comment faut
faire vous avez intérêt à être juste
dans vos dans votre approche et je me
suis aperçu d'une chose c'est qu'en fait
des abeilles
on ne peut pas leur donner d'ordres
l'apiculteur n'est pas un manager
autoritaire est obligée d'entrer en
relation avec un monde étrange
différents automne en stupéfiants et
finalement la meilleure solution quand
on est apiculteur c'est déjà d'écouter
de comprendre ce qui se passe dans une
ruche d' essayer d'interpréter tous les
signaux qui se passe bien sûr aussi en
s'appuyant sur des connaissances que
l'on a et finalement je me suis aperçu
que l'apiculteur il n'a pas d'autre
solution que d'accompagner des abeilles
c'est une posture qui vous oblige à
aller dans le respect dans la relation
dans les écoutes à l'école des abeilles
j'ai appris la force et l'importance de
l'humilité
ça fait maintenant trente huit ans que
j'ai des ruches ont pas beaucoup une
quinzaine je les ai installés dans deux
ruches est différent pour avoir du miel
différents tout simplement
alors quand vous mettez plusieurs ruches
côte à côte et bien chose étonnante
alors que ces abeilles ces colonies
d'abeilles ont exactement le même
environnement floral la même météo et
même le même apiculteurs et bien elle ne
donne pas les mêmes quantités de miel
chose étonnante chaque ruche en quelque
sorte sa propre personnalité
certaines sont plus ou moins douce plus
ou moins populeuses plus ou moins
agressive plus ou moins dynamiques et au
bout du compte la récolte de miel
variera de manière assez significative
on s'aperçoit que le vivant mais pas une
mécanique le monde du vivant mais
beaucoup plus subtil et complexe le
monde du vivant
il est étonnant il est incroyable il
nous oblige à le comprendre
à l'écouter à être attentifs
finalement le monde buvait du vivant
quand j'ouvre mes ruches
j'ai deux sentiments un premier
sentiment celui de la beauté
une ruche quand vous ouvrez une ruche
c'est extraordinaire tous ces 1,7 tous
et à celles qui font le buzz qui dansent
pour communiquer entre eux
tu développes d'état de stratégie pour
se synchroniser avec le monde floral qui
entoure la ruche dans un rayon de
quelques kilomètres
j'ai un sentiment de beauté et la beauté
c'est tout à fait essentiel mais j'ai un
autre sentiment
j'ai le sentiment de fragilité de ces
insectes
depuis 38 ans j'ai vu la situation de
mes abeilles se dégrader les maladies se
développer leur santé est de moins en
moins bonne
la fécondité des reines se réduire j'ai
même vu j'ai même vu des tas d'abeilles
mortes un intérieur des ruches
cette équipe est en fait le monde du
vivant nous donne plein de leçons mais
moins face à cela face à sa beauté est
aussi sa fragilité
j'ai fait le choix de partager ma
passion ma connaissance des abeilles
c'est ma manière à moi de réparer une
planète qui va pas très bien et j'en
parle beaucoup je partage ma passion
j'essaie d'expliquer de faire comprendre
et d'alerté
finalement le monde des abeilles m'a
appris la puissance de l'émerveillement
de la pédagogie de l'émerveillement pour
entrer en résonance avec le vivant
dans une abeille c'est un petit insecte
assez modeste
il pèse moins d'une dizaine la dixième
de gramme
c'est pas grand chose une abeille un
petit insecte essayant par ci par là
oui mais dans les abeilles elles se
mettent ensemble pour former une colonie
qui est une colonie puissante qui est un
groupe important dans lequel il a entre
10000 et 60 mille abeilles un nombre
incroyable qui va varier selon la ponte
de la reine quand le printemps arrive la
reine se met à pondre apprendre à pondre
et le nombre d'abeilles progresse de
manière incroyable jusqu'à atteindre
durant les beaux jours
cinquante soixante mille abeilles les
abeilles elles ont une capacité
étonnante celle de transformer le monde
un allant chercher des matières
premières dans le l'environnement de la
ruche dans l'environnement floral elle
vous cherchez du nectar pour le
transformer collectivement en miel elles
vont chercher du pollen pour le
transformer en pin d'abel qui va nourrir
les petites larves les abeilles elles
vont aussi chercher la propolis la
propolis qui va assurer par ses
propriétés antiseptiques la salubrité de
leur petit habitat la rue isabelle de ce
point de vue là peuvent être comparés en
quelque sorte à une industrie
transformer le monde à partir de
matières premières mais il ya plus d
abeilles réseau aussi une autre capacité
celle de polliniser les fleurs d'aller
d'une fleur un autre pour transporter le
pollen de la fleur à à la fleur b et
d'ainsi assurer la possibilité des
fleurs de se transformer en fruits en
grain quelque part la ruche c'est aussi
une société de services
ce service c'est quoi c'est mettre des
gens en relation ou des individus ou des
acteurs en relation pour qu'il se
développe se transforme s'améliore la
ruche c'est vraiment à la fois
comparable à une industrie ou à une
société de services alors du coup c'est
un petit peu l'organisation idéal on se
dit c'est un modèle parfait et bien là
je risque de vous décevoir mais je vais
vous dire moi je j'aimerai pas être une
à bell je préfère être un humain parce
que en fait ce qui est complètement
génial incroyable fascinant dans
l'organisation de la ruche c'est sa
capacité à s'organiser à travailler
ensemble en équipe pour transformer et
embellir le monde sur le comment faire
ensemble
les abeilles sont imbattables il y à là
plein d'idées à aller chercher à
comprendre desquels on peut s'inspirer
par contre la question du sens la
question du pourquoi
c'est souvent le propre de l'homme est
en fait nous des humains
on a besoin de savoir comment réussir
ensemble mais aussi pourquoi de faire
alors ma démarche qu on appelle souvent
de biomimétisme
en fait moi je préfère parler plutôt de
bio aspirations parce que en fait des
abeilles nous inspire comme tout le
monde étrange et différents qui nous
permet de mieux comprendre la complexité
la beauté du monde pour savoir comment
agir réagir et surtout agir ensemble les
uns avec les autres à l'école des
abeilles j'ai appris la puissance de
l'inspiration
dans une ruche dans une russe
il y à pleins d'abeilles qui vivent
ensemble
mais attention je ne vous parle que des
abeilles agnel parce que des abeilles
rien qu'en france il ya eu baisse de
1000 espèces différentes d'abeilles qui
sont souvent solitaires 10 vivent en
petits groupes et là je vous parle
uniquement de la bei à miel de la bei
qui constituent une population très
nombreuse qui va varier de plusieurs
milliers d'individus selon la saison et
ses abeilles elles agissent
collectivement de manière solide de
manière avec une sorte d'intelligence
collective remarquable
en fait chaque abeille a comme projet de
faire réussir toute la ruche et c'est ça
qui est le plus fascinant et en plus les
abeilles je me suis aperçu du fait que
chaque butineuses ramène le butin à la
ruche et le butin est réparti entre
toutes les abeilles de la ruche
quel que soit leur rang quel que soit
leur âge
quelles que soient leurs besoins aucune
abeille n'a fin à l'intérieur de la
ruche autre chose étonnante dans la
ruche la température est une constance
celle du confort des abeilles et les
abeilles vont réguler ensemble la
température selon lui fera froid en
hiver ou trop chaud l'été elles
s'organisent collectivement pour adopter
un système de thermorégulation assez
étonnant en fait les abeilles s'adapte
aux changements climatiques et nous les
humains nous sommes plus de 7 milliards
dont au moins un milliard ne mange pas à
sa faim tous les jours
quant à notre capacité collective à
s'ajuster au changement climatique
c'est pas gagné finalement partout
dans toutes les civilisations partout
sur la planète
les abeilles sont un symbole de
solidarité à l'école des abeilles j'ai
appris la nécessité et l'importance de
la solidarité
j'interviens souvent dans des
organisations dans des entreprises
la première chose que je fais pour la
décrypter
je dessine l'organigramme aussi je me
suis mis en tête de dessiner
l'organigramme de la ruche dans la ruche
comment faire finalement dans la ruche
cohabitent deux fonctions celle de la
production
elle est entre les mains des ouvrières
bien nommé et celle de la reproduction
qui revient à la reine et au mal
évidemment la reine et bien par sa ponte
elle va réguler selon les saisons
la population des abeilles mais elle
n'aura pas de rôle l'hiérarchie tu sur
les abeilles ouvrières qui travaillent
en autonomie en auto organisation qui
constituent des petites équipes qui se
débrouillent sort de sans respecter les
ordres d'une reine qui ne leur en donne
même pas en fait dans la ruche chose
étonnante chaque ouvrière va changer six
fois de métier ce n'est pas du
taylorisme chaque abeille va évoluer au
début de sa vie elle va d'abord être
nettoyeuses ensuite nourrissent ensuite
elle va contribuer à la construction des
rayons de cire
elle sera aussi ventile deux gardiennes
et ensuite du team 2
elle va aller chercher le butin qu'elle
ramènera à la ruche et tout ceci est
d'une durée variable selon les besoins
du contexte de la saison et s'adonne à
la ruche une agilité incroyable quant à
la reine eh bien elle
elle a un rôle de pompe comme je voulais
dit on a un deuxième rôle 13 ans
pourtant elle produit chaque jour de sa
vie pendant les années où elle vit à
jets continus hiver comme été et aussi
bien le jour que la nuit une hormone
c'est une hormone de cohésion que toutes
les abeilles s'échangent entre elles en
permanence par des petits bisous tout à
fait sympathique et en fait la reine ça
n'est pas la chef mais elle pratique un
leadership par la cohésion
alors maintenant les mâles dont les
mâles y pense qu'à une chose s'envoyer
en l'air avec de jeunes reines pour les
féconder ainsi la logique de la ruche
c'est une logique dans laquelle chacun
n'obéit pas à un ordre mais se
positionne plutôt dans une logique de
contribution qu'est ce que moi je vais
faire pour mon équipe
qu'est ce que je vais faire pour la
réussite de l'ensemble de la pologne à
l'école des abeilles
j'ai appris l'importance des logiques
contributives
et puis il ya cette magnifique relations
entre les fleurs des à mèze un jour les
fleurs inventaire un stratagème pour
disperser leurs pollens parce que quand
vous êtes une fleur vous êtes là plantée
sur vos racines c'est pas très facile de
faire des rencontres amoureuses
il faut un agent de liaison ce sont les
pollinisateurs
les abeilles finalement elle assure en
allant d'une fleur à l'autre la
fécondité des fleurs et ce rôle elle est
incroyable il ya là une alliance
magnifique entre eux le monde végétal et
le monde animal
une sorte de relation gagnant gagnant
un cercle vertueux magnifique et
incroyable
en fait des abeilles quand elle butine à
la fois elle ramène le butin pour le
jour même à la ruche et en même temps
elle contribue à la run au
renouvellement du système floral pour
l'année prochaine ceci sans avoir jamais
bouquins sur le développement durable
incroyable les abers à l'école des
abeilles j'ai appris l'importance de la
logique de l'alliance de la logique de
l'alliance les uns avec les autres
avaient tous les êtres vivants tels
qu'ils soient à quelles que soient leurs
différences
finalement à l'école des abeilles j'ai
appris une chose importante c'est plus
nos liens sont plus essentiel que nos
biens
c'est ça le principe de la vie et nous
les humains avec nos toxines et notre
égocentrisme
des fois on oublie un peu c'est
dramatique parce que le vivant s'en
porte très mal aussi
je voudrais vous lancez un appel
il est fondamental de sauver les
abeilles
parce que j'en suis convaincu sauver les
abeilles c'est sauver l'humanité à
l'école des abeilles
j'ai appris plein de choses en fait je
fréquentais l'ena l'école nationale des
abeilles
comme vous le savez et à l'ena on
apprend plein de choses importantes
l'humilité la logique de l'alliance de
la coopération en appelant en a prend
plein de choses fondamentales telles que
celles ci alors j'ai quelque chose à
vous dire je préconise que vous toutes
et tous tous les humains
suivent l'enseignement de l'école
nationale des abeilles merci
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]